الجراثيم الخارقة هي جراثيم قادرة على التعلم
والتطور مما يجعلها مقاومة
للمضادات الحيوية المصممة لقتلهم
يموت ما يقرب من 36000 أمريكي من
عدوى البكتيريا الخارقة كل عام وهو
حوالي واحد كل 15
دقيقة وفقًا لتقرير مراهق لعام 2009
من مركز السيطرة على الأمراض يحذر من بعض الأدوية المعجزة
لم تعد  نفذت المعجزات
تقول الوكالة إن هناك خمسة
جراثيم خارقة مقاومة للأدوية تشكل تهديدًا عاجلاً
للصحة العالمية ، وجد باحثون
وراثيون أن بعض الجراثيم يمكنها مشاركة حمضها النووي مع
جراثيم أخرى بشكل فعال لتعليمهم
كيفية التغلب على المضادات الحيوية المعقدة
يقول مركز السيطرة على الأمراض إن معظم الوفيات الناجمة عن العدوى المقاومة للأدوية
ناجمة عن الجراثيم التي
توجد عادة في المستشفيات ، لكن التقرير يشير إلى أنه في
حين أن عدوى البكتيريا الخارقة من المستشفيات
قد انخفضت عن دراسة 2013 التي تم
اكتشافها في أي مكان آخر
في المجتمع ، يشير الخبراء إلى
الإفراط في وصف المضادات الحيوية
كعامل وراء تنامي مقاومة الأدوية
و  يقولون السبيل الوحيد لمنع
ظهور إعادة المضادات الحيوية  العدوى المقاومة
هي إذا عمل الأطباء والمرضى وواضعو السياسات
معًا في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم
أنا بريت كونواي